the Honeydew with Ryan
[Music]
sickler welcome back to the Honeydew
y'all we're over here doing it in the
night pant Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler docomond on all your social
media and I'm going to start this
episode like I start all of them by
saying thank you thank you very much for
supporting this show uh thank you for
supporting everything we do here if you
haven't subscribe please it's a free
easy way to help the channel out um and
if you got to have more than I'm telling
you you got to have the patreon go watch
the recent Josh Wolf episode where we
highlight the low lights of the patreon
some of our favor because it's the
Honeydew with y'all and y'all have the
craziest stories I've ever heard in my
life there's nothing like it out there I
promise you um and the new podcast the
way back thank you for the support I'm
stoked for it we have so many recorded
already very excited to bring that to
you guys as well uh tour dates
everything is over at ransler all right
that's the biz you guys know what we do
here we highlight the low lights I
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and I am very excited
to have this guest on first time here on
the Honeydew ladies and Gentlemen please
welcome Le Cher welcome to the Honeydew
a thank you so much I'm so happy to be
here this long overdue oh a well thank
you well I I came to um see you guys and
do your shows and stuff over there and I
was like I got I want you to come on cuz
I'm going to tell you this I want to
give your husband gave me my flowers I'm
going to give you your flowers the wife
of the party listen it's it's the best
name for a podcast out there it's so
creative it's so smart it's so on point
it's it just Nails it it [__] Nails
it it's so good thank you it's so good
and to be the wife of the party like
that I am yeah I know and to know the
story before the wife came in and all
that like holy [__] so lean Cher welcome
please plug promote everything you would
like and then uh we're gonna get into
your story okay well obviously wife the
party podcast I've had it for 300 plus
episodes I love my podcast we talk about
everything and nothing and it's great I
just produced my first standup special
for Shane Torres I'm really proud of
that it's on YouTube you can watch it on
Burke Cher's Channel or Shane's Channel
and I think I mean I love Shane but I
think we did a really good job I was
really proud of myself um so yeah and
then obviously always ber Berber b.com
you know always be selling bber
b.com but yeah I guess that's it wife of
the party podcast well I I don't know a
lot about your upbringing and uh but I
hear I catch the these things from Bert
from Kirsten from whoever here there so
I want to talk to you about your up
upbringing because you're where were you
born originally you're you're from the
south obviously so here's what else is
funny people constantly tell me I have a
Southern accent do I sound Southern to
you no exactly and I say that to them oh
you must sound to me like I sound to
them for whatever reason right right um
I draw my O's and my A's and it's a it's
a draw it's not a southern accent like
accent's a different hit no it's
definitely not yeah no most people think
I'm from Texas but my accent's very
different than Texas but if you're not
from Texas or from where I'm from you
just everybody thinks everybody's from
Texas I think so where are you from I'm
from bden Georgia oh you're from Georgia
yeah Bowden has about 1,600 people my
daughter's Middle School had 1,800
people so slightly different than my
upbringing the LA school out here had
200 more people than your
Town your whole the whole town I
remember being there the first day of
middle school and going yeah this is my
entire Hometown in one building and my
kids were like yeah it is crazy man that
math is hurting my head yeah in one
building one building so this is in
everyone knows everyone in their
business Town yes joke but true sort of
true joke but true and do you have um
extended family or is it just brothers
and sisters all in that you're an only
child only child and do you have cousins
and stuff that live there though I have
cousins I have one other cousin that
left actually two cousins that left one
is still in Georgia and one moved to San
Francisco everybody else is still there
yeah um in that same town pretty much
yeah yeah and what is it now do you know
the population now uh about the same no
way yeah it's about the same nobody's
moving just
D no I know when I was in high school
you know I think four or five of us went
to college we grad I graduate with 74
people my graduating class so yeah it's
kind of your whole senior class was 74
uhhuh my whole senior class 74 and I
moved around my parents divorced when I
was seven so but everyone that I started
kindergarten with in that town I
graduated with in high school because I
went back there for high school I see um
and every you know everybody knew
everybody I had like three options for a
boyfriend in high school and they were
all my third cousin not not not a joke
or I my boyfriend in high school when I
finally broke up with him my dad was
like thank God you know he's your cousin
and I was like what you could have given
me a heads didn't tell you that at all
no he was like well I knew it wasn't
going to work out so I was just waiting
for it to fall apart but yeah so what's
Mom do what's dad do you're an only
child and then they divorce so tell me
about that Mom and Dad were from
neighboring hometowns um my mom's
actually from Alabama so my hometown is
on the border of Alabama
so uh they were high school sweethearts
got married three weeks out of high
school after my mom graduated and my dad
is a mechanic he went to school to be an
auto mechanic had his own shop my first
job was working for him I I um kept his
books and then when I turned 16 I drove
his tow truck you did I swear to you
were telling people I did I I swear were
you really who are you yes
I pulling out of the [__] every old man
in his overalls I'd up and they go
where's your daddy and I go well he's at
the shop well who's going to pull my
truck in well I am and they were like no
you ain't going to hook this up and I'm
like I've been riding record trips with
my daddy since I was eight years old so
I'd just hook it up and pull it to the
shop and these old men would get and do
they ride with you in the C yeah and
like what I didn't know Jimmy's daughter
did that and I'm like well you know the
good thing about my daddy is I don't
think he ever really saw me as a girl or
a boy just as a kid mhm so he never
really treated me like oh you're not
doing that girls don't do this boys
don't do this yeah good I like that he
was just like if we're chopping wood you
are also yeah I grew up in my friend's
dad's junkyard and we had ladies like
that too like I'm like you're going to
drive that and she's like yeah I'm GNA
[__] drive that I'm like God damn she
would drive the [__] out of it too yeah
yeah so 16 you're just getting your
license and you're doing that yeah well
I've been driving you know cuz my dad's
um family had a 88 acre farm so I'd been
driving for a long time by the time I
actually got to legally drive but anyway
so my parents were high school
sweethearts my dad was a mechanic my mom
worked in a factory selling men's suits
to pay his way through school mechanic
school and then when he graduated very
liberal of my dad he said well what do
you want to do it's my turn to pay for
you to go to school and she wanted to be
a model so and she's very beautiful um
so he paid for her to go to barbazon
modeling school remember barbon yeah
went to barbazon and when I was four she
went to Chicago to uh catalog model and
just didn't come home for like a year
and a half wait what yeah just kind of
went a goodbye just split and stayed
just split stayed I think she came home
once or twice in that year and a half
but she stayed there and uh that kind of
was really hard for my dad my dad sort
of unofficially had a bit of a nervous
break down like I remember getting up at
for kindergarten and him just just
sitting at the table just staring off
into nothing making myself waffles and
you know he's a great dad but he was
just really in love with her and she
just broke his heart so when she came
back from Chicago but also left you yeah
so he's watching his little girl without
a mom too this dude's without a wife
you're without a mom is this okay she's
up
here without a wife without a mom mom I
stayed with her parents a lot um her dad
suffered from really severe PTSD from
World War II and was probably the
meanest person I've ever known like got
in a fight hit somebody with like a
logging chain in the head um just real
mean nasty guy so I was really scared of
him I didn't enjoy staying at their
house but I stayed there till my mom
came back and when my mom came back she
kind of plotted to leave my dad so um
that's when the games began with my
mom a here she go run from me she get
out so yeah my mom came back from
Chicago um what made her come back do
you know I think um I think my dad just
kind of stopped sending her money so he
was sending her money to support he he
was fulfilling his end of the bargain
I'm going to support you and get you up
and running but at a certain point he
figured out that she was this was she
was kind of conning him a little bit
um so he just stopped sending her money
so she came home when she got
home ah this is just so not fun but she
she had gone to Atlanta found an
apartment rented an apartment fully
furnished it without telling him and
basically was like I'm going to leave
and he was like what's going on let's
let's have like a a trial period where
we see if this can work here and she
agreed to it while she finished amassing
everything and then left him and left
with all the credit card debt and took
me to Atlanta yeah took me to Atlanta
which was really devastating for me
because I was on this farm right I I had
a calf every summer I had to raise I
worked on the farm all my cousins not
yet later though but I had all these
cousins I was totally surrounded by
family and then she moved me to Atlanta
in um and in a community in Atlanta that
was all gay men in the 70s because she
thought a little girl would be really
safe in the gay community so she moved
me into the gay community and um and did
you know you were going or did you wake
up one day and Mom's just driving uh
told any heads up I didn't have a lot of
a heads up but I know she told me that I
had enough time to give my dad my
favorite toy and he still has that toy
it broke his heart I gave him the toy
that I slept with every day because I I
was you know he and I had been
Inseparable for a year and a half and
then all of a sudden she showed up and
everything changed it was really hard um
but after we moved to Atlanta I started
figuring out my mom was not right in
that and this is my opinion my mother
has not been diagnosed with anything
that I know of but I noticed at a young
age that she lied quite a lot and I
would catch her in the lie and you know
when you're like seven or eight you go
hey that's not true and then when you
say hey Mom that's not true I would get
in trouble for that and she would tell
me it was true true
um and you know she started having me
steal things from places why what cuz
she wanted them and she didn't want to
pay for like what what are we talking
about what do you she really liked sugar
dispensers and she like [__] sh she
liked large
knives and she liked large serving
spoons in restaurants so it was always
from a restaurant it was never what's
one of her favorite spots where are you
going well I don't know cuz we went to
Everybody's Pizza a lot and what called
everybody's pizza everybody's pizza and
you would be stealing [__] from there
yeah and I hated it because I was like
this is so wrong how old are you eight
can you I can't imagine that my kid be
like get that
spatula get that spatula just stick it
down your pants stick it down your pants
she would go if they catch you you won't
get in trouble cuz you're a little girl
so just put it in your pants and I'd be
like oh my God I'm just going to just
keep walking keep walking keep
walking so there was that and then she
was dating this guy that that we would
take suitcases full of cash to the
Cayman Islands on a regular basis so
some part of me was like I don't know
what this is and her and her the three
of us oh she was seeing the guy yeah she
was seeing the guy we were here's my
little suitcase full of money cash he
owned arcades and junkyards jard I tell
it's cash business cash yeah so that was
happening in Atlanta and then my dad's
house my dad was living with two other
bachelors in a log cabin that had no
heat on 20 acres of land we had to chop
wood I lived with them every other
weekend and then all three months in the
summer so I jokingly say I'm a perfect
fit for Bert because I grew up with like
three bruh major bachelor party every
weekend women in and out I mean it was
like a frat house and that's where I
felt really safe because my mom Not only
was lying was had a lot of men in and
out and um didn't really have a lot of
friends and I think when I was young I
just was like something's up here like
something's not the elevator's not going
to the top floor um when I was Middle
School she moved us to a suburb and I
guess I always knew something was really
off but when we moved to the suburb I
had a neighbor across the street whose
family was like oh no you need to kind
of stay at our house oh really yeah they
told they sort of like took you in yes
and then what were they seeing just the
[__] that's going on a lot of yelling
and screaming a lot of your at you your
mom you a lot of um hardcore criticism
of of me of I didn't really the way she
worked now that now that I'm an adult
and I've read a lot of books and I've
been in a lot of therapy I really think
she had a borderline personality
disorder called narcissism as a disorder
that's what I believe again she's not
been diagnosed so I can't say that's
factual
but my experience of her based on what
I've read is pretty much that so if I if
you told me if I said hey the inside of
your mug is green and she didn't think
that was true I would be punished for
that just me going but hold on that's
green so why am I in trouble she was
very um she may me take like 21 vitamins
every day I had to drink niin when I was
a kid she was very controlling of my
bowel movements like she would monitor
my bowel movements and
watch me to make sure I had them like
[__] like not normal stuff yeah that's
not normal it's not normal she was naked
a lot like all the time she was always C
he said a lot then he said like all the
time all
the like she vacuum naked she was naked
yeah she was always naked she was a
model actually by the way she ended up
being the highest paid model in Atlanta
for like nine years she was a runway
model in Italy she was like a model yeah
my mom I don't look like my mom I look
like my dad she's like 5'8 blonde green
eyes sh shar's body not my body shar's
body and she would just roll around
naked in front of you always yeah would
this be when you had company as well or
she crazy enough to keep it together
remember I grew up in the gay community
no there those guys wer over there all
the time well there's no kids I had no
friends good point there's no kids in
that community so yeah it was not super
awesome it was really lonely and I was
stuck with this lady who was always
naked and so um obsessive about what I
was doing and what I was you know eating
she was also kind of macrobiotic so I
could only eat what she told me so she's
projecting all that model insecurity
mental illness [__] on you with the
bowel movements and what's going in and
out of the body and it was insane man
you're being regulated like that she's
watching your [__] yeah she watched me
[__] okay not to get too graphic but she
would like put newspaper on the floor
and go do it wait not on a toilet what
do you mean I swear oh so she's
humiliating you too she's not just
monitoring it yeah it was bad man I'm
sorry it real bad and then I had my dad
who was just a freaking awesome he's
just taking it off the floor and be like
yeah well maybe now he was just like
what can we do today let's go you know
take a dune buggy up the side of a
mountain let's go look for rattles snaks
in the wood you know listen that's what
that's interesting to hear you say
that's where I felt safe you're talking
about Ratt snakes and Buggies and ladies
in and out and you're like this is where
I safe oh listen we had to build a
chimney on this Log Cabin to heat it
right so we had one fireplace only and
it was in the living room so to heat the
bedrooms my dad was building this like
wood bur burning furnace that he
actually ducted through the house but we
had to build the chimney so there's one
mountain in our hometown called
Blackjack Mountain and Blackjack
Mountain is covered in rattlesnakes so
me and my dad and his room roommate got
in his Jeep and put a trailer on the
Jeep and my dad would turn a rock over
and Doug would shoot the rattlesnake
that was under the Rock and then they'd
hand The Rock to me to put in the
trailer [__] that chimney right now okay
and you pick up I'll sh out
[__] that's also one rock that's that's
one rock yeah you got a lot more rocks
we did that like four weekends in a row
hell all the Rocks build this damn
chimney yeah one summer I had to dig a
ditch cuz the the basement was flooding
and I had to dig a ditch that was the
length of the house and the width of the
house how old are you doing this [__] 12
13 like oh younger 101 mm he bought it
in 1980 taking a trench around the house
for yeah that's what we did bunch of
beer a little bit something on the radio
dig dig dig cutw all year and I was so
happy to be there I would have done
anything not to be at my mom's house and
you're only getting the weekends and
then the summer and the summer yeah but
Monday to Friday is Mom yeah naked mom
naked mom who's just torturing you yeah
it was pretty rough man so yeah my when
I Middle School we moved that family
across the street they were moving and
the dad called me in his the kitchen and
he was like Hey I I actually can't leave
you here I I'm building a house I'd like
to build a room for you I'd like to
legally adopt you if that's okay with
you and I would was so embarrassed
because I thought oh my God they found
out like they know that my mom is not
right it was really embarrassing so I
was in eighth
grade and actually when when my mom got
custom me custody of me the the judge
was like at 13 she can choose wherever
she wants to live so I knew I was going
to move with my dad after 8th grade so I
said thank you you know but I'm going to
I'm going to live with my dad but that
was probably one of is that right 13 is
why you can do that so you decide on
your own okay sorry I interrupted you
that was that was one of what that was
what that was one one of the hardest
moments is that I someone saw me and saw
um that it was rough you know you can
kind of pretend like everything's okay I
don't have any siblings it was just me
and her and a cat so you could just kind
of act like nothing's I'm good I just
got to wait 12 days to get two days of
normaly with my dad then I wait 12 more
days to get two days of normaly and then
I got to make it to Memorial Day and
then I got 3 months of normal Sharon
Judy Garland for [__] 12 Here Comes
daddy Here Comes daddy so I got a
question that just popped in my head I
want to ask and I want to get back to
you but
um raising your girls even though we're
out here and your life is so different
have you seen the little Leanne in their
school have you seen that girl you know
have you been able to identify one where
you're like I'd like to or have you
helped anybody like that yeah I have
yeah I have a Girl Scout Troop you know
I've had for 13 years and we had a girl
in that Troop that all I have two other
leaders all three of us were like this
girl needs all of us needs everyone here
and needs the three of us adults in
particular and at some point um she she
stopped coming and we tried everything
we could to get her to keep coming and I
mean to pick her up to drop her off just
whatever we could and um couldn't make
it work here's the thing I was the kid
like I felt like so after my dad died we
were 16 like everyone it was right at
Thanksgiving so all of a sudden there's
this bunch of donations Anonymous
donations Christmas presents closed from
all all the wonderful people who meant
well and all I could feel like was a
[__] charity case and I was
embarrassed I was humiliated I was angry
like [__] these sweatshirts or [__]
these people and they're you know what I
mean like I didn't mean that but I was
just like this I don't want any of this
this isn't what I want or need and I've
been able to do that too and a few times
in life where I'm like oh and it's all
so scary I remember being a kid like why
should I trust this one this one [__]
is trash oh yeah you know and then for
you to have these three ladies that want
to look out for you it's also a little
bit um nerve-wracking to be like do I
give my trust in these people absolutely
you know it's hard to believe someone
can love you when the one person that's
supposed to doesn't know how amen she
she just doesn't know how I mean what
what causes narcissism as a disorder is
serious childhood trauma which I believe
she had I mean her dad was a disaster he
was an
absolute meanest nastiest man I've ever
seen until he got diagnosed with PTSD
and got medicated and then he was
actually really great you really saw a
different
are you kidding wow he would oh my God I
would hear him hit the front porch
screaming and cursing at my grandmother
where's my goddamn lunch may I mean from
the minute he walked on the porch and
when he got medicated he just started
crying he cried and cried and cried and
cried but he was you know he was on
Hiroshima 30 minutes after they dropped
the bomb and his job was to find surv
and take them to medic oh my God yeah I
mean come on that's insane yeah how do
you come back from that how do you how
do you raise three children and be kind
and soft you can't do that he was just
trying to not see Japanese bodies all
the time and didn't tell anybody until I
was
in probably uh probably I was eight or
nine years old when he finally got
diagnosed and then started getting
treatment that's who raised her so you
go well I understand why she's broken
and I I have no hard feelings with her
I've I had all that when I was younger I
really forgave her for a lot of stuff
but but when you decide to choose your
dad do things get even worse with her or
is it just cut off cold like how does
that go down well this this starts
though you make the choice yes I do uh
this starts phase two of and her
relationship really phase two is you're
dead to me I don't see her talk to her
for like a year and a half or so and
then she I was a cheerleader in high
school she just showed up at a ball game
like nothing happened and then I'm a
teenager going well I guess okay so I
guess we're making up now you know
that's just how it was just poof out of
nowhere I'm at this game y not I'm
coming no heads up it's just that is
narcissistic as [__] isn't it yeah just
to show up show up like that especially
was she
naked she may as well have been because
you know she was this big fancy model
coming back to her small Hometown and
this is like it was as if Sher came
right to my ball game um so yeah then I
just started in a relationship with her
again because she's my mother and it
went on till 23 and then can I ask you
another question this whole time that
you choose to live with your dad how far
in proximity is Mom aou miles like
Atlanta how far is Atlanta from that
about 50 miles so all right an hour yeah
so not three states over like if wanted
to could absolutely have had a
relationship with her daughter had to
drive through my dad's Hometown to get
to her parents house and did do that oh
I'm sure she did so she bounced to
Chicago and now she's staying in Atlanta
and both of you now bye-bye W yeah yeah
so did I mention she's been divorced six
times
you forgot the six marriages she was
working on number seven but I think he
might have got wise and got out early
before he got trapped yeah she's six
divorces she ain't healthy y'all she
just ain't healthy bless her heart you
know I don't want anybody I genuinely
would hate to to to be as angry as she
is and live her life every day that
angry that's just not any way to live
you know that's it's really sad it
breaks my heart for her but yeah she uh
I was dead to her for a while and then
she came back and then we you know were
s sort of okay for a little bit and then
I was bopping around in college I was
miserable in college we even talked
about the redneck stuff I grew up with
that I'm sure Bert's T to you about
that's the stuff I want to talk to kon's
told me some things so should I stop
talking about this cuz that's way more
fun no no we could talk about we'll
we'll get to all of them we're not in a
hurry did Bert tell you that when my dad
first met ber he was living in a
yeah that's what he told
us I could live here I could
live first of all
okay when I first started dating Berke
okay I said to him I'm a little
concerned about you meeting my family
because I don't he's from a pretty white
collar you know he's from Florida which
gives it a different element yeah but I
mean dad's a lawyer mom's very
educated um was an educator her parents
were like they're just White people I am
not from that big time and I was like oh
my dad's actually currently living in a
convenience store and that was from up
from the cabin yes from the cabin my
dad's currently living in the
convenience store and my grandfather
wears overalls every day of the week I
mean he has a Sunday pairer for church
and then the regular payer for I mean
like and definitely is an old school
Southerner if you know what I mean
really nice man but very old school
Southerner and I was like how in the
world am I going to make this happen so
I kind of pre Bert on the way to Bowen
explaining my family a couple people
might cook meth just
saying one or two have some missing
teeth and that's why so just buckle up
and that's you know just hope for the
best and we went in that convenience
store and in the middle of the
convenience store is a pizza oven and B
was like there's a there's a pizza oven
in here wait a minute you mean you go
through the beer cooler and on the other
side of the beer cooler is my dad's
apartment which has no windows so it's
pitch black but he had a great couch he
had a great couch the couch reclined and
he also had a
recliner and BR was like hold on you
mean you can get up any time of the
night and go in the other room and get
snacks and then my aunt also worked
there who makes the best biscuits ever
and so as soon as you wake up in the
morning you can have like biscuits and
gravy and whatever you want he thought
it was a dream met my grandfather hasell
who was the best Storyteller I've ever
been around and as you know Bert is one
of the best storytellers and my pop just
told him stories all day the first day
they were inseparable and I was like
okay well that's working my dad's
working just avoid the two toothless
cousins in the corner and we can get out
here un scathed but yeah when my dad
first met bird he was like I'm G to tell
you something boy that's the best frog
gigger in the county is Leanne and Bert
was like what does that even mean what
does that mean well we used to when I
was a kid we would we didn't have any
money so we would Camp a lot and my
grandparents had this farm that had a
river on it so you get in a John Boat a
flat bottom boat with Spotlight and you
just frog gig all night long you just
reach in the bank and grab frogs some
people do it with like a pole a forked
pole but we didn't do that we'd just
grab it with our hands just trolling
along and snagging them just grab it
with your hands and then what do you do
with it you put it in the well of the
boat and then you eat them oh you do go
home and eat them yeah we eat frog legs
yeah fry them up mhm yeah yes I've had
frog legs they're not bad they're not
bad they're not bad they're fine it was
fun I mean as bizarre as that may sound
it was so was by the way shooting
rattlesnakes out from under rocks Prett
fun to build a chimney not just for fun
to build a chimney it was a purpose it
was build a chimney it worked and then
we finally had heat that's it was
freezing in that house I don't know
anybody how to do that to get heat kill
rattlesnakes oh we did have a snake that
lived in our Log Cabin so we had a rat
snake that lived in my dad's bathroom
because what's better to take care of
rats than a snake and most people don't
really understand that perspective but
my family always had snakes because they
take care of rats and we have Farm yeah
you have a farm you kind of need that so
anyway I had that too that was kind of
bizarre get started on your resolutions
with Factor they're ready to eat meal
delivery takes the stress out of meal
planning and sets you up for success in
the New Year skip the grocery stores
prep work and cooking fatigue instead
get chef-crafted dietitian approved
meals delivered right to your door with
over 35 meals plus over 55 weekly
add-ons to choose from including options
like keto calorie smart vegan plus
veggie and more you'll have a ton of
nutritious and flavorable options to
pick through Factor now even offers
loads of snack options like breakfast
smoothies juices and more to keep you
going no matter what's on the schedule
when things get hectic factor is
flexible change your order up every week
with plans from 4 to 18 meals per week
or pause and reschedule your deliveries
anytime head to factor meals.com honeydo
50 and use code honeydo 50 to get 50%
off that's code honeydew 50 at Factor
meals.com
honeydo 50 to get 50% off do you ever
feel like money is just flying out of
your account you have no idea where it's
going well I know it's all those
subscriptions think about it between
streaming services fitness apps delivery
services parenting apps it's endless I'm
guilty of it so I use rocket money to
help me find out what subscriptions I'm
actually spending money on and which
ones I had been forgetting about for
months rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds any cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps lower your bills I
can see all my subscriptions in one
place if I see something I don't want I
can cancel it with a tap I never have to
get on the phone with customer service
they'll even try to get you a refund for
the last couple of months of wasted
money and negotiate to lower your bills
for you by up to 20% all you have to do
is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest
rocket money has over 5 million users
and has helped save its members and an
average of $720 a year with over 500
million in cancelled subscriptions stop
wasting money on things you don't use
cancel your unwanted subscriptions by
going to Rocket
money.com honeydo that's
rocket.com honeydew
rocket.com honeydo the farmers dog was
founded by two dog lovers who decided to
reimagine pet food from the ground up in
the 5 years since they delivered their
first meal the response has been
incredible the farmer's dog makes and
delivers fresh healthy dog food it's
developed by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from real healthy
ingredients to human food safety
standards it is the best option for dogs
at all life stages because it's not
kibble it's not Kang goo it's just real
healthy food not only that it's also
pre-portioned specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
this makes it easy to help your dog
maintain their ideal weight which is one
of of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life doesn't matter if your dog
is young or old it's always the right
time to begin investing in their health
helping you live more healthy happy and
full years together get 50% off your
first box of fresh healthy food at
thefarmersdog.com honeydo plus you get
free shipping just go to farmers.com
honeydo to get 50% off that's Farmers
do.com honeydew now let's get back to
the D what else I used to drag race for
money in high school where hog liver
Road like just on the street yeah yes
there wasn't a track there wasn't a
quarter mile track no did you just say
hog liver Road
I our our intersection is that the
straightest uh spot to do it it's kind
of in a holla
so it's very hog Li R I'll tell you what
right now [__] I see all down
hog Li r
there's no way to say that that it's
real though it's real people don't
believe it's real it's real my the
intersection of my street where my dad's
Farm my grandparents Farm was called Bug
scuffle so You' go to bug scuffle and
take a right on the hog liver off a bug
scuff on DOT road is that right it's DOT
road yeah I love this anyway so um all
right how much are you winning you just
going like 50 a pop or what are you just
drag racing against all dudes too it was
all dudes are you the only girl like in
the group of every guy 100% the only
girl yeah that was only girl all the
time I went everywhere with my dad and
he did Dad stuff he went to tractor pull
we went to demolition
derby um I want to go I can't find one
iol Derby Irwindale Speedway every other
month it is awesome yes in Irwindale I
go I take Isa all the time every other
month every other month I'm definitely
gone I want to take my daughter so bad
to that so fun all right called night of
Destruction it's a different kind of
redneck we used to go to these tracks it
was a place called 75 and 80 cuz it was
at the intersection of 75 and [__] 80
and the Rednecks all the fat guys would
take their shirts off and then it was
locals that would bring their Nova in or
their souped up Cino or whatever and
they would warm their tires up and light
them up here and these guys would be
like wo and stand there and let those
little pieces of gravel and rubber just
all over them and they would stand there
like that I'm like what the [__] are you
all doing it's a different kind of
mentality redneck right I remember in
high school the boys used to stir up an
ant bed and stick their hand in it for
money whoever could leave their handing
it long the money and you're like
what I mean could you imagine some La
kids doing that [__] no no way no no way
yeah that was off and done so that's so
Dad moves at what age are you living in
the convenience store or you never so
you grew up in that cabin I did uh my
dad and I did build a house from the
ground up when I was about 14 so we
moved out of that house into the house
that he and I built you literally built
a house to I did I didn't put the roof
trusses on and I didn't do the
electrical wiring um but I help you
built your shelter M my dad and I did
yeah my dad and I taught me dad my daddy
was the real deal [__] it sounds still
is very handy yeah hand's an
understatement he like bet bet your
mom's looks are long G but Dad skill
still around [__] I still got
these that's the Dre he's the best he's
the sweetest and the best I would not be
this person without my daddy for sure
that's great to hear would not be this
person without my daddy no way so yeah
um yeah he and I built that house we
lived there for a little bit and then we
moved back into the Log Cabin because we
didn't like it we like the cabin better
so we moved back and did you have your
own room mm you did it was a big cabin
it actually was like a four bedroom Log
Cabin um and he had like I said he had
the the roommates so I had were those
were good dudes by the way awesome dudes
you still in communication with anybody
all of them I could be I'm not but I
mean when I got married to Bert I um as
I don't have my mom I drove myself to my
wedding in a pickup truck I did did you
really I did you drove yourself I did I
didn't think about it you know I think
the thing is when you grow up by
yourself the way I grew up you just
don't think about it you just do cuz you
need to do and if you don't then
nobody's coming that's right nobody's
coming to drive that [__] truck
that's not it's true you know and all
this crap with my mom my dad is such a
sweet kind of as much as he was a party
guy he was a really fragile guy like
emotionally really really fragile kind
of like Bert really sensitive some
anxiety issues which you know back in
the 70s you didn't know what that was
but yeah he he uh remarried when I was
19 he'd been with her since I was about
eight and and um she left him and when
she left him he had a he had a legit
nervous breakdown and moved into the
dorm with me in my college no swear hold
on a second you can't just say that [__]
like
[Music]
it's tell me after your Dad's second
divorce he moved into your college
door I can't
imagine right now
but would though he would he would just
be like Georgia move over there's no way
he could make it it's the same person
there's no way it's not a mystery I
married this guy who's the most fragile
frat boy on the planet that was my dad I
mean my dad wasn't a frat boy your dad
moved into your dorm it was how you
get bet it was I it was [__] it was
rough he's not moving in for party time
no he's not he was moving in and you get
away with he was crying a lot he was
crying a lot he would sit on the couch
in the dorm Lobby and just wait
for I can't imagine seeing this poor man
just saw it and you're trying to [__]
live your life and being in college
you're finally out of the house yeah it
was pretty bad it was pretty bad oh [__]
it was pretty bad um I got to wait with
it because um I was I was in a wait what
school did you guys go to it was West
Georgia College it's now University of
West Georgia or West Georgia University
something like that but yeah so in my
home there was pretty close to my
hometown I was in a sorority and you
couldn't live in a sorority house
because it was considered a brothel if a
certain number of women live in a house
together it was a brothel so we had a
dorm floor so my my sorority dorm floor
was all my shorty sisters and I just
explained it I was like listen I don't
know what to do my dad's in pieces so my
roommate kind of moved out and moved in
with her boyfriend and my dad moved into
her bed I don't remember how long he was
there like maybe a month you have like
bunk bed with your dad or like the two
twined beds my
dad my
God it's got to be the saddest [__]
thing to see just to be a fly on the
wall and see your look on your face and
he's over there sobbing and [__] soing
you're trying to it was awful you know I
get out of school and he'd be waiting
for me on the couch and then he want to
go like Drive the streets to the city
drinking bwise or looking for his wife
and it was like oh my God it was bad
bless his
heart you
know now I would I would never do that
to my kids but I guarantee you if I did
that to Bert Bert would definitely be
moving in with Georgia 100% so sorry
Georgia you didn't hear it your dad that
was so funny so for a month that's a
long time it was a long time I was a
sophomore what made him finally say all
right I'm [__] out of here he meet
ended
no not that deep Bud the semester ended
it was over time to get home I was sure
he met someone new no no no no no no no
he didn't mean anybody new for a long
time but you know time time heals all
wounds I guess he just kind of got over
it and I moved to Atlanta I was like I
got to get out I got to get out too good
that is good crazy crazy so now you're
in Atlanta but isn't that where Mom is I
was living with my mom again cuz
remember at 13 we reestablished our
relationship I moved in with her at that
point God there's a lot about my life I
guess I started drinking when I was 13
and by the time I was 20 surprised it
wasn't I know right I'm surprised it
wasn't me too I'm shocked I don't drink
anymore I mean I do drink some but yeah
by the time I was 20 um I'd had a DUI
I'd gotten arrested for vandalizing
people's homes what were you doing I was
throwing rocks in Windows just for fun
just to [__] do it I was angry mhm I
DUI um and then still drinking my 21st
birthday I drank like a a fifth of vodka
by myself I was drinking that much and
then that was like a regular thing uhhuh
it was pretty regular and then I started
losing my hair
and um from the drinking M and I started
bloating really badly and then uh moved
to my mom's cuz uh I was in bad shape
and I was getting away from the
situation with my dad and my shorty had
actually done an intervention on me and
told me I needed to go to reab kicked
and stripped me of all my offices and
the sority and I was like [__] all you
people I'm moving and moved to Atlanta
to get away like we're out of here we're
[__] out of here we're going to e
Georgia Mother exactly
so then my mom took me to the doctor and
the doctor was like this is from alcohol
her liver is actually quite enlarged and
I was like I don't drink I don't know
what you're talking about totally lying
um kept drinking kept driving drunk
massively and then I woke up one day I
was just driving and I was like this is
I'm not happy I'm massively unhappy and
I don't think it has to do with alcohol
I think there's something else wrong
like I'm really unhappy so I dropped out
of college my mom's fourth husband at
the time was very wealthy and said what
do you want to do I'll help you any way
you want to help want help he's the
nicest guy ever and I said I think I
just want to move to New York City and
just take like a year off college and
just figure my [__] out I need to get
out of Atlanta I didn't make any friends
in Atlanta so I was like a boy in a
girl's body and in the South like you
have to be sort of girly and I just you
know was raised by three men really so I
just couldn't find my way there so I was
like well I'd love to go to New York and
he said well I'll pay your rent for six
months just your rent and you take care
of everything else and then uh you know
I'll sign the lease over to you or you
move or whatever and I was like that's
amazing
thanks did that then and stopped
drinking entirely I was just like I'm
just going to stop cold turkey and
figure out why I'm so unhappy so I moved
to New York and shortly after that and
got to therapy shortly after that my mom
decided to reinvigorate her modeling
career and move into my apartment with
me come on wait first of all two
questions how old is she at this point
when she's reinvigorating the career I'm
23 so she' be
43 okay so it's not the end of the
career but it's going to be a different
career it's not the runway uh young
fashion model anymore no but she got JC
Penney and Sears
and BR totally but you know she's
beautiful she's blonde she's tall she's
beautiful okay but now she's coming to
your place she I had a studio apartment
and is that leverag because husband
number four is paying for it so she's
like [__] You I'm coming and staying to
your [__] correct man you can't get a
goddamn minute to yourself you ready
it's still better she starts [__] the
neighbor across the
street and says to me you got to
lie to my husband about this and I said
I'm not doing that I don't lie for
myself I'm not lying for anybody no so
we get in a fist fight in my own
apartment and she kicks me out my own
apartment no you got a fist fight with
your mom mhm I did I I hit her actually
I had just had where get her I hit her
first in the middle of the chest with my
fist you punched like that I just
punched her and I wanted to knock her
down that's what I was trying to do just
knock her down and she didn't get
knocked down so I just kept shoving her
and shoving her and shoving her until I
got I I just had to I just went hold on
I am out of control now and I need to
leave so I left and she let me be gone
so she set a bag out and I was out of my
own apartment I was about 10 days I had
nowhere to live so I just went from like
Lobby to Lobby to Lobby in apartment
buildings and just kind of went I got a
friend that lives here I'm just going to
hang on the couch till he gets home or
whatever and would not off and sleep a
little bit and
then uh I was trying to be an actor
because I was trying to figure out what
I wanted to do so I was an acting class
coincidentally with Miss Georgia and my
teacher was like something's going on
with you and I don't know what it is
but what's happening and I told him
everything that was going on
coincidentally my mother had also joined
my acting class get the [__] out is it
really coincidentally no it's not
coincidentally that's right no she
joined my acting class which I went to
my teacher went please no so he put her
in a different one so that we weren't
actually in class together so he knew
who I was talking about because he
taught her also and um went to Miss
Georgia and said can you let her sleep
on your couch until and help her find a
place to live and she did Stephanie
Michelle's I will be very grateful for
her forever but I also like you were
talking about being embarrassed once I
finally got up on my feet I was so
embarrassed that she'd helped me that I
like was an [__] to her and years
later found her and apologized to her
wrote her a letter I was like I just I
just don't I didn't know how to accept
help and I was so
embarrassed um but yeah and she she and
I are fine now we're you know not
friends but fine um be I lived in uh
Spanish Harlem for 3 months scared out
of my mind this was in '93 so it's a
little different than basically Alabama
to Spanish Harlem yes I remember getting
off at the Port Authority I'd never been
to New York I just moved there I just
thought it it's it's not working here
let's just go there and uh the port you
know 42nd Street was like Peep Show Peep
Show Peep Show trip xx movie nudy NY
prostitute everywhere on 42nd street
when I first moved there dead bodies in
Alphabet City everywhere it was like it
was before they cleaned it up so it was
really pretty rough but I ended up
living there for like four years but
yeah my mom when she kicked me out I was
dead to her then too so it happened at
13 and at
23 and then I got subpoenaed to core to
testify on my stepfather's behalf
because she claimed all these things
that were not true and uh other things
happen I don't feel comfortable saying
here but I'll tell you later if you want
to know di you had to go to court
against your mom yes but she settled the
night before I had to testify so I
didn't actually have to go but there's
nothing worse than walking through an
airport and someone saying are you my
name's my first name's Kelly are you
Kelly kimp yep you've been served and
open it up and find out you have to
testify against your own mother you in
the airport where they got you
mhm you can't do that [__] anymore not
anymore they were right outside the gate
not anymore this was 93 or 94 yeah so
that happened and so we split up for a
while and then I went on with my life I
moved to LA I met Bert fell in love with
Bert and
uh uh Bert and I got pregnant on the
pill um no swear I was on the pill got
pregnant we we'v been dating for like
over a year he already bought me a ring
I didn't even know it but we got
pregnant on the pill so my mom wasn't
talking to me then either uh we had
gotten back into talking and I'm my 20s
but she was mad at me cuz I wouldn't do
something she wanted me to do so she
wasn't um responding I kept calling her
and going you need to call me I need to
tell you something like really important
never call me back emailed her you need
to call me I need to tell you something
because I was going to get married we
like had shotgun Mar where marriage we
got married in like two months she never
called me so finally I sent her an email
I said listen you're not calling me back
so I need to tell you I'm pregnant and
I'm getting married and I want you to
know and I want you to come to the
wedding and the email I got back from
from her email first of all an email
email was so bad that I printed it out
and gave it to Bert's sister and she
cried and I went I am keeping this email
forever because I will never ever
forget how sick she is so in the email
again she said you're dead to me I don't
want to know you I don't want to know
your husband I don't want to know your
kids you're so disrespectful for telling
me in this manner and whatever her crap
was and that that's the last time I
really had contact with her I saw her at
her dad's funeral and uh how long had it
been oh long time and she did bust in on
I I always brought the girls to see her
parents because I wanted them to know
their
great-grandparents and I had a good
relationship with them I mean [__] who
has great grandparents anymore right
yeah I mean they just lost my mom's mom
like a year ago wow so yeah I mean
everybody has babies young in the South
y'all so you know but yeah she busted in
on one visit with them literally walked
in the door just like my cheerleader hey
y'all I'm your naughy and my kids were
like George was like eight she never
seen her before ever and then I saw her
again at her dad's funeral and that's it
I don't what was that like it was you
know we were you talk at all we were
cordial to each other she introduced me
to her sixth husband there um and uh and
then coincidentally my dad's mom had
passed away within a couple days so her
funeral was the following day and she
showed up at my grandmother's funeral
who I was very close to and did one of
these pulled me outside and uh with my
kids gave my kids each a gift and then
proceeded to lecture me about respect in
front of my children and how I have no
respect I have never had any respect I
don't know how to respect and how
disrespectful it was for me to come to
her dad's funeral and and my kids were
were like what and I actually talked to
my kids about this not long ago I was
like do you remember that and Georgia
said yeah I just thought she's crazy and
I'm like might not be and you held it
together you don't believe [__] you lady
no I just go okay after all these years
you're just at that point like all right
it's not even worth it anymore for you
yeah it's like this is GNA if she ever
hears this she'll be really mad it's
almost like when a homeless person is
talking nonsense to you and you have
sympathy and you go oh yeah totally I
completely yeah there are definitely
aliens in your tent 100% I agree yep you
probably should look into that yep
that's kind of how it is cuz she's just
so not on this planet but how's Dad like
how's your relationship with your dad it
amazing my dad comes out here every
three or four months he's taught my kids
how to build stuff you know how to fix
their car how to you know he built all
the mic stands out of wood in our whole
studio he and I build Furniture together
all the time we have a great
relationship and I take my kids back he
has a house on the lake in Alabama we go
there every summer they um bird adores
him he adores my dad he's just the best
he's great he's he's been with his he's
not married but he's been with his
girlfriend for 23 years now they're
happy he's got three sort of step kids
with her so he's good he's all
good so do you like look there's no way
you can tell your kids like you don't
even know you know what I mean like cuz
they they'll never get that never I mean
even no offense kids who aren't in the
situation your kids are in there's
there's no lower middle class kids out
there building their own [__]
chimneys no it's probably not you know
what I mean like that's that's way
different than any so how do you like
how do you balance that with your kids
how do you or do you find yourself
overdoing it overcorrecting like how do
you do that as a mom well I take them
home every summer and for two weeks
since they were born and we float the
river we frog gig we build stuff we we
sleep on the ground um not on a cot like
I did Growing Up I when we went camping
we didn't have a tent what do you mean
you slept on the ground we put sleep on
the ground no like when we go camp
camping okay um so we do that um we take
a dock bath you know when we're at the
lake house we soap up on the dock and
jump in the lake and that's a bath you
know so that's what I grew up doing so
as as much as I can you know my cousins
are walking around no shirt pistol on
their hip there's always snakes in the
river when we're in the river I mean
they've my kids have seen my cousins
shoot a snake
um you know so I try to give them that
that little two- week window of what
that part of the world is like because
what I feel like too is we we La is such
a bubble it it's not really it is a
reality but it's not the only reality
and my reality was amazing I in so many
ways that I couldn't possibly give them
here so like we we went to Montana with
another family that's born and raised in
La uh originally from Boston so super
City people uh went to Montana and there
was this convenience store that had
Taxidermy literally on all four walls
like on top of the freezers like
everywhere and her two kids were so
flipped out and my kids didn't even
really notice it
because when you go back to my hometown
that's the way it is there too and I had
to explain to her kids you know hunting
is not what you think it is in my
community you actually eat what you hunt
I mean I grew up eating deer and we grew
everything we ate on the farm we had
cows and pigs and goats and chickens oh
you would eat those too oh yeah oh okay
you're not just using them for dairy and
all that no we weren't a dairy farm no
yeah so they had cattle farm they 250
had a cattle but he would always put one
cow up for our family and he raised pigs
for the family he raised chickens and
goats for family if you a butcher yeah
takes a cow how many like how many
people could that one cow feed I don't
know but but it filled up a big freezer
my grandmother was a lot right steaks
and burgers and everything else you can
get the [__] out of that thing yeah and
the pigs yeah and my pop had his own
Smoke House so he smoked everything
there was a dairy farm down the road
they would trade with with uh grew a
whole big vegetable garden there's very
little they they bought very little from
the store so I feel like I I feel like I
got the opportunity to have the last
little window of this old that's the
most [__] La upbringing these people
want you know what I mean they all want
to go [__] far that's right they all
want to go farm the table and this and
that and and you're really [__] doing
that [__] back then you're like oh
you're going to kill this cow cuz we're
going to [__] eat this thing you know
these chickens these [__] whatever
yeah they don't that's the whole [__]
woke [__] out here they all want to
be like that and not one of them's like
that out here it's so hard that life is
so hard here's what I like about what I
what you're saying I actually love about
it because you're saying it's so hard
but you also said you loved it no I did
I love you didn't hate it you didn't you
don't you don't uh tell your kids like
[__] seeing that part of the world cuz
you don't yeah I really like that you
embraced it no we we've they've
definitely seen us like clean fish filet
fish like right out of the lake and I
don't think a lot of kids get the
opportunity to see that either here you
know yeah I love the way I grew up I
would not trade I actually wouldn't
really trade my mom either because I
learned a lot about human behavior from
her you know knowing when someone lies
I'm pretty good at that because you know
you read your mom differently than you
read other people and when you can see
those kind of inconsistencies in your
mom it makes you feel unsafe and that
unsafe piece you can spot in other
people very quickly so that's a a good
tool I also have no ability to filter
things because she filtered everything
everything was a con and I just went I
will not be doing that because it's so
unsafe because you go well are you
asking me to do this I was just saying
this to Bert I remember when in high
school she gave me a really nice purse
and my instinct was to give it back
because the purse was too expensive for
me so what she would ask asked me to do
because she'd given me a gift was too
expensive I didn't want it I I don't
want what comes with that gift exactly
yep I know that so then it makes me give
gifts with absolutely no attachment I
don't even care if you like it to throw
it in the garbage if you don't like I
don't give a [__] take it back return I
don't give a you're not going to hurt my
feelings uhuh doesn't work like that for
some other people though you
realize oh you really upset all right my
bad sorry what's for Bert Bert gave me
oh my God
the worst he gave me a gold velour
tracksuit what part of me looks or
sounds like I would wear a gold vour
tracksuit he is 6 fo2 with a belly it
looked great on him and I opened it and
I went oh man I'm never going to wear
this and he has never forgotten it so I
was like this is not I mean gold jewelry
is one thing but an
entire what is wrong with you dude and
he's like oh I can't just can't buy
gifts for you ever um listen thank you
for coming on here and doing this
episode before we go yeah I want to ask
you advice you would give to because
this is interesting I'm curious what
you're going to say advice you would
give to 16-year-old
Leanne I would say what's your name
again my name's Leanne my first name's
Kelly Kelly and what was your M name km
so what advice would you give to Kelly
Kim uh I would say it's I don't know if
it's advice or maybe like just it's all
going to be okay that was such a mess at
16 it's all going to be okay cuz I am so
happy and balanced and fulfilled and at
peace with the things I was not that way
about at 16 I think that's what I'd say
it's going to be okay that's great I
agree I think about the things I thought
about at 16 and how much it meant now
I'm like
God if you only knew how it means
nothing nothing I mean nothing nothing
nothing um thank you very much please
plug and promote anything you'd like
again just wife the party podcast Shane
Tor a special yeah on it's called the
blueeyed Mexican on YouTube all right
thank you very much as always Ryan
sickler on all social media Ryan sickler
docomo talk to you'all next
[Music]
week
[Applause]
[Music]
oh